vielleicht wohnt ja sogar in österreich
und wollten kommen dann können wir das
ja machen
hey leute was glaubt jetzt willkommen
beim neuen video ich bin gerade hier in
österreich kennt ja wahrscheinlich so
ein land das so unterhalb von
deutschland im skiurlaub also schildert
mine life aber eigentlich wollte ich
skifahren sieht doch ganz cool was soll
ich euch gleich ich habe mir gedacht ich
hatte jetzt nicht ganz so viel zeit
irgendwas cooles überlegen weil ich auch
noch für mein abi lernen muss weil ich
jetzt beim abi schreibe aber ihr könnt
wirklich ganz bescheuerte fragen stellen
und da werde ich mal wieder ein bisschen
drauf eingehen war ja auch schon lange
nicht mehr so dass über fragen habt habt
ihr auf install macht daher sich alex w
's kurz eingeblendet wenn ihr das noch
nicht kennt dann checke das ab ja ich
will gar nicht lange lagern wir fangen
direkt an mit frage nummer eins und die
kommt von kleiner mekka das passt
eigentlich ziemlich gut diese keime
fragt wie gefällt es dir in österreich
und ja eigentlich gefällt mit ziemlich
cool ich kann euch ja mal kurz hier auch
ein balkon zeigen wie das so abgeht hier
ja leute wir gehen jetzt einfach mal
raus
das ist hier ein cooler balkon mit einem
coolen stuhl und generell in österreich
ist es ganz cool da hinten sind die
berge sieht auch ganz nice oder freche
aber das so gut erkennen können aber
eigentlich schon und schnee liegt grad
nicht so viel aber da hinten ist
trotzdem die piste wo man einigermaßen
nein nicht gut fahren kann ja so sieht
hier aus an sich ganz cool
die nächste frage kommt von bet xl xxl
was würdest du tun wenn du dich einen
fan küssen würde und du nebenbei eine
freundin hat ist das würde mich mega
interessieren du kannst du stellst jetzt
vor ich bin irgendwann kommt irgendein
und sagt ja auch keine videos oder wie
ganz normale reaktion ich würde sagen
was los mit dir dein herz grad so sowas
will ich nicht unter meinen zuschauern
haben das ist voll eklig
es sei denn sie es gab so aber wenn ich
neben meiner freundin hätte selbst wenn
die dann geil wäre würde ich nichts
machen
hoffe ich nicht so vollkommen von
mariniert oder so und zwar fragt sie
welchen lehrer wirst du nie vergessen
ich kann jetzt hier schlechten namen
sagen allerdings gibt schon ein paar
lehrer denkt möglich
irgendwie war es so richtig lustig zum
beispiel mein alter chemielehrer der war
so vergesslich der wusste gar nicht
welche leute wirklich in seinem kurs
sind und welche nicht derart selbst
leuten die ein halbes jahr nicht daran
weil es im ausland waren oder sonstwo
wenn zwei gegeben obwohl die gar nicht
da war der kante hat die namen nicht
oder so war fragt mich nicht wie das
geht ja also das war schon echt cooler
typ den werde ich bestimmt nie vergessen
irgendwie auch immer das gefühl der war
besoffen im unterricht und die elena
simon fragt willst du öfter mal eine
skivereine habe mal nicht so legen wie
sie eigentlich liegen sollten
manchmal ganz selten das ding ist bei
mir immer wenn ich morgens aufstehe und
vor dem spiegel drehte denke ich mir
direkt da siehst du heute wieder gut aus
viel besser als gäste also das ist halt
so ich sehe jeden tag auch mal ein
stückchen besser
nein das war kein spaß klar dass kennt
doch jeder sowieso man denkt sogar heute
musste man richtig gut aussehen weil du
hast echt oder so und genau an diesem
tag sehen dann deine haare deiner
meinung nach scheiße aus aber von
anderen meinungen das habe ich letztens
in meinem letzten video gesagt andere
finde ich auch ist auch egal so die
swiss fragt wie viele beziehungen
hattest du schon zwei alte leute erstmal
ganz anderes problem ein rücken tut
somit vom china das ist echt heftig ab
irgendwelche tricks oder sowie das weg
geht auch so wie viele beziehung ich
hatte im 2 beides sehr liebe mädchen
wenn ihr das seht die begrüßte gehen
raus und euch und ja aber ich habe
gesagt ich werde beziehung nie wieder
öffentlich machen das heißt ob ich keine
freundin habe oder nicht
wer weiß ich lange research ist auf
jeden fall eigentlich hat als bei
freundinnen beiden richtig cool aber
irgendwann nicht mehr so gefasst und ja
jetzt gerade habe ich halt wegziehen und
kommen wir auch schon zum nächsten fall
und zwar von alex wie fakten trinkst du
gerne alkohol da hab ich mir gedacht so
wirklich so ich bin jetzt kein typ der
so richtig gerne alkohol trinkt früher
war das mal mehr da dachte man soll ja
heute ist wieder angesagt so stimmt was
auch nicht aber ich halte davon heute
irgendwie nicht mehr so viel so
gelegentlich oder halt wirklich jede
woche so alkohol zu trinken mit seinen
freunden keine ahnung ich habe auch
überlegt so das war ein video zu machen
wieso das erste mal alkohol bei mir war
wo man so meiner meinung nach darauf
rücksicht nehmen sollte und das war's
bisschen gechillt angehen lassen soll
also da will ich gerne mal ein video zu
machen sobald mein erstes mal ein cool
wenn ihr noch drauf habt könnt ihr mir
gern kommen nach oben geben dann sich
das ja ja das kann man halt auch mal
schnell so nebenbei neben dem abi noch
abdrehen und dann werden wir ab gehen
borders hat sich geräumt nein heute spaß
bereitet das war erstmal ich muss
erstmal wieder mein flug auch wenn mich
irgendwann von euch gerne passieren
würde das könnt ihr mir das ja gern mal
in die kommentare schreiben vielleicht
wohnt ja sogar in österreich und gold um
kommen dann können wir das ja machen
ansatz würde ich sagen das war's mit dem
video wenn ihr bock auf weitere fragen
antworte videos habt dann folgt auf
instagram und könnte mir daher demnächst
wieder fragen stellen da nach oben der
cool abonnieren ich vergess und gangster
zu verbessern slapshot ins leere weil es
ein gedicht über links geht's weiter mit
meinem letzten jahr das müsste auch auf
jeden fall nochmal abzocken wir sehen
uns aber ich weiß es nicht morgen
übermorgen sonntag erst wieder kann ich
nicht sagen weil ich noch ein video auf
die reihe
komm runter alter weil ich noch ein
video auf die beine stellen kann
ja ihr seid cool ich auch weiß was los
hat mit mir